[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: Machine
learning is awesome,
except when it forces
you to do advanced math.
The tools for
machine learning have
gotten dramatically better,
and training your own model
has never been easier.
We'll utilize our
understanding of our dataset,
rather than an understanding
of the raw mathematics,
to build a model that
gets us insights.
Welcome to Cloud AI Adventures.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
On this show, we'll
explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
While machine learning might
be a great conversation
topic at dinner parties, it's
even more useful with code.
In this episode, we're going to
train a simple classifier using
only a handful lines of code.
In fact, here's all the code
that we'll look at today.
To train our
classifier, we'll use
TensorFlow, Google's open
source machine learning library.
TensorFlow has a pretty
large API surface,
but the part we care about
today is just the high level
APIs called estimators.
Estimators package up
the training loop for us
so that we can train a model
by configuring it, rather
than coding it by hand.
This takes away much
of the boilerplate,
allowing us to think at a
higher level of abstraction.
And this means we'll get to
play with the interesting parts
of machine learning, and not get
too bogged down in the details.
Since we've only covered linear
models so far in the series,
we will stick with that here,
and revisit this example
in the future to extend
its capabilities.
So with that, let's
dive right in and
go to our Jupiter notebook.
OK, so here we are in
our Jupiter notebook.
And the first
thing that we'll do
is import TensorFlow
as tf and numpy as mp.
I like to print out the
version number of TensorFlow
below to confirm which
version I'm using.
This week, we'll
be building a model
to distinguish between three
different types of very
similar flowers.
I realize that this may be
less interesting than the beer
and wine from the
previous episode,
but these flowers are a bit
more difficult to distinguish,
making this a more
interesting challenge.
In particular, we'll be
classifying different species
of iris flowers.
Now, I'm not sure I could pick
out an iris flower from a field
of roses, but our model is
aiming to distinguish iris
setosa, iris versicolour,
and iris virginica.
We have a dataset
of measurements
of the height and width of these
flowers as petals and sepals.
These four columns will
serve as our features.
So let's load our dataset
in using TensorFlow's Load
CSV with Header function.
The data or features are
presented as floating point
numbers, and the label for
each row of data or target
is recorded as an integer--
0, 1, or 2-- corresponding to
our three species of flowers.
Now I've printed out the
results for our loading,
and we can see that we are
now able to access the trained
data and the associated
labels or targets
using named attributes.
Next, we'll build the model.
To do this, we'll first
set up the feature columns.
Feature columns define the types
of data coming into the model.
We are using a
four-dimensional feature column
to represent our features, and
calling them flower features.
Building our model using
estimators is super simple.
Using
tf.estimators.LinearClassifier,
we can instantiate the model by
passing in the future columns
we just created.
The number of different outputs
that the model predicts--
in this case, 3--
and a directory to store
the model's training
progress and the output files.
This allows TensorFlow
to pick up training
later on from where it
left off, if needed.
This classifier object will
keep track of state for us.
And we are now almost ready
to move on to the training.
There is just one
final piece to connect
our model to the training data,
and that is the input function.
The job of the input
function is to create
the TensorFlow operations that
generate data for the model.
So we go from raw data
to the input function,
which passes that data that
is then mapped by the feature
columns to go into the model.
Notice that we use the same
name for the features as we
did in defining
the feature column.
This is how the
data is associated.
Now it's time to
run our training.
To train our model, we'll
just run classifier.train
with the input function
passed in as an argument.
This is how we connect
our dataset to the model.
The train function handles
the training loop and iterates
over the dataset, improving
its performance with each step.
And just like that, we've
completed 1,000 training steps.
Our dataset's not huge, so
this completed rather quickly.
Now it's time to
evaluate our results.
We can do this using the same
classifier object from before,
as it holds the trained
state of the model.
To determine how
good our model is,
we run classifier.evaluate
and pass in our test dataset.
Then we can extract the
accuracy from the metrics
that are returned.
96.6%.
OK.
Let's pause here and review
what we've achieved so far.
The estimator's API has
given us a nice workflow
of getting our raw data and
passing it through an input
function, setting up our feature
columns and model structure,
running our training,
and finally,
running our evaluation.
This easy-to-understand
framework
allows us to think about
our data and its properties,
rather than the underlying math,
which is a great place to be.
Today, we looked at
a very simple version
of TensorFlow's high level
API using a canned estimator.
In future episodes,
we'll look at how
to augment this model with more
details, use more complex data,
and even more advanced features.
Thanks for watching that
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
You can catch the
whole series here.
And if you have any
thoughts and comments,
feel free to leave
them down below.